[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones is set to
showcase its big battle between the
night Kings forces and the newly formed
union of Westeros in the upcoming
episode naturally anticipation is at a
fever pitch right now and fans are
eagerly waiting to see which one of the
Starks will make it out of the showdown
please be Tony please be Tony please be
Tony however there is another theory
floating about that says we might
actually be getting back a long-dead
member of the family during the battle
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down all of the evidence that
supports that there may be some spoilers
here so if you want to go into the
episode as blind as possible then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
with that out the way huge thank you for
clicking the video I hope you enjoy it
now let's get into my breakdown of the
Ned's not dead theories the big battle
between the White Walkers and Jon Snow's
forces is about to begin and whilst the
citizens of Westeros are apparently
tucked away safely in the crypts of the
city there's a big flaw in that plan our
heroes seem to have forgotten that the
whites namely the knight King have the
ability to raise the dead and therefore
this is probably a worse hiding place
and the one Saddam Hussein picked in the
Iraq war the Starks have ruled Westeros
for 8,000 years so potentially there are
a countless number of corpses stuffed
away in their crypts that could add a
legion of undead to fight for the night
king stark has long been theorized to be
returning to the show and this seems
like the perfect opportunity to bring
him back to prove that Sean Bean doesn't
always die for good so what evidence is
there to support this well in the promo
trailer for the upcoming episode there's
a moment where Daenerys tells John the
dead are already here
this of course signifies that there are
hundreds of corpses within the city
walls and therefore the night king he
doesn't even need to send his army in
Vladimir Ferda could place a night king
also recently teased a resurrection
scene in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly there's a
moment in hardhome when Jon Snow was on
the boat and the night king looked at
him and raised his arms there's a
similar and even stronger moment between
John and I King this time could this
perhaps confirm that the night king will
fly over the city and raise the dead to
me yes remember he doesn't even need to
touch a corpse to reanimate it so this
could potentially be the method that he
uses to destroy the city from the inside
out the last two episodes of the season
have been about bringing people together
for Pleasant reunions so this new
release could focus on nightmare ones we
won't know for sure until it's out but
even george RR martin has referenced the
undead rising from the tomb in the book
a game of Thrones in that story Martin
had Jon Snow have a nightmare in which
he saw his dead family members rise from
the Crypt in the following paragraph
last night he had dreamt the Winterfell
dream again he was wandering the empty
Castle searching for his father
descending into the crypts only this
time the dream had gone further than
before in the dark he'd heard the scrape
of stone on stone when he turned he saw
that the vaults were opening one after
the other as the dead Kings came
stumbling from their cold black graves
Jon had woken in the pitch dark his
heart hammering this would be an amazing
easter egg for fans of the source
material and it would be brilliant to
see a return of all the family members
for this big reunion of course Ned
doesn't have a head anymore I call him
no head Ned back from the dead by the
way at the moment there but I can't
really see provided much of a threat
because of that but the rest of the
family on the other hand could be
terrifying and this would explain why
Arya looks so scared in the trailers
obviously we will find out next week if
this is the case but in the meantime I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the theory
and if you think I'll happen
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out my breakdown on everything you
need to know about the night King which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
Definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]